can you get a good bagel in wyoming  um i mean those supermarkets have bagels  oh oh god oh my goodness okay i feel  really bad for you that is what that's  that's a bad answer i mean it's you're  not nothing you're lying  like there's like einstein  oh god oh my god i'm gonna have to let  you go okay  okay i feel it wow wyoming i feel sorry  for everybody there okay thank you i  appreciate the call  uh man that is the that is disturbing  your choices are einstein brothers  and which actually it's not that bad  actually when i was when i was in  arizona recently i got i had no choice  but at the start of a drive i picked up  an einstein brothers bagel it was i  actually wasn't terrible but  and then your freezer aisle of  supermarket bagels that's that's pretty  tough